[Music]
you've spent years hearing about
advances in AI from programs that beat
go and chess grandmasters to smart
assistants hey Alexa play my coding
playlist and facial recognition I ruff
you AI is changing how we live now
you're ready to take the next step and
learn AI yourself you know where you
want to go but you don't know where to
start
that's why we built the AI programming
with Python nano degree in two months or
less you'll build your own AI
application using deep neural networks
from scratch learn all the key AI skills
in one place such as Python linear
algebra and deep learning with Python
and get the support you need for success
with mentorship and project reviews
our AI experts so what are you waiting
for join us to start building your AI
skill today
[Music]
you